hey everyone this is kevin from the
chess website comm and today we are in
Game five of our coverage of the 2016
World Chess Championship the first four
games have all been drawls last two have
at least been entertaining Magnus
Carlsen had a advantage in both of them
in game 3 much bigger advantage was
unable to find a victory in either of
those but he does have the white pieces
in game 5 so looking to actually get
that first win in the tournament 7k
cardiac him been playing amazing defense
but that's kind of always been playing
for 4 games now his defense so he's
gonna be looking to kind of reverse that
role and finally find his first win in
the tournament so we're gonna get
started Magnus Carlsen starting with
pawn to e4 pawn e5 Knight f3 knight c6
and it almost seemed like this was gonna
be the tournament of the right Lopez but
we see Bishop to c4 so Magnus Carlsen
changing it up a bit playing the Italian
game Bishop to c5 going into the quiet
game and then castle on the Kings side
now main line from here would just be to
play pawn to c3 then push forward here
to d4 Magnus Carlsen decided to change
up a little bit castle on the Kings side
the knight here to see six and then pawn
to d3 so eventually Magnus Carlsen in
any one playing this opening
particularly eventually gonna want to
play pawn to d4 but decides he wants to
wait a little while develop his board
stay a little bit more and then
eventually push forward here to a d4
cardiac team castles on the kingside
pawn to a4 so Magnus decides to go ahead
and push a little bit on the Queen side
before he starts to push in the center
of the board pawn to d6 solidifying the
pawn chain as well opening up the door
for the LightSquared bishop to get
involved into the game and then this
pawn to c3 very important getting ready
to push pawn to a d4 Knight to or pawn
to a6 upon appear to be for forcing the
bishop back here and this ponte to a6 is
is interesting cuz he has a few options
you can play pawn to a6 you could also
play pawn to a5 but then it's a little
tricky I think for black his Magnus
Carlsen we played Knight to a3 and then
they look to play Knight here to b5
putting a lot of pressure on black side
of the board so I think karyakin
rightfully played pawn to a6 it's one of
these small things that you don't think
about too much but I think a lot of
operation went into this pawn to a6 move
but pawns have B for recognizing he's
not gonna be taking his night out right
away since he can't come here to be five
but pawn here to be for Bishop comes
back a seven recover here to e1
protecting this pawn in the center of
the board
Kuryakin continues with Knight to e7 and
notice when the knight was on c6 its
defending this central square of d4 very
important square in this opening
especially with this Bishop here on a7
everything is kind of gearing up for an
attack in the stern of the board once
madness cross and pushes forward with
pawn here to d4 soon as this knight
moves though magnus carlsen needs to
start figuring out how he wants to
attack the stern of the board it'd be a
mistake if he attacked right away pawn
to d4 we could see them exchange right
here bishop down to a g4 pinning down
the knight if we try to kick this night
away I'm going to say pawn to h3 we
could just take on here on f3 if the
Queen recaptures what she needs to then
this Fischer could take on d4 does not
have the protection that he needs so it
doesn't want to do that right away but
first he decides to go ahead and play
Knight to d2 this is nice because now if
there ever is a pin down here with the
bishop on g4 he could actually protect
it with the night you could recapture
and still have his queen protecting the
center of the board now I have to worry
about this Queen recapturing here on f3
so he did kind of wait for his opponent
before he played this night to be good
too because generally he would be
looking to get his Bishop involvement to
the game and then push forward but
decided not to do that
now after Knight to g6 then Magnus
Carlsen decides okay I can go ahead and
push forward with d4 and it's any time
you look at this openings you know some
of the moves look somewhat complicated
some of them look a very basic but you
can get yourself in a lot of trouble if
you're playing lines that you're not
familiar with and you're not really sure
when you should push forward when you
should get your knight involved into the
game what you're looking from your
opponent so if you have different
openings that you play make sure you
study them and you're aware with all
these different nuances that your
opponent can play so pawn to c6 cardiac
and says I'm gonna go ahead and kind of
play a similar game as you I can push
forward with pawn to d4 if I need to he
does have this Knight and now this pawn
protection as well as this Queen back
here
to attack you if you wants to pawn to h3
madis carlson doesn't want to have to
worry about the bishop ever coming here
even the night from f6 coming down here
to g4 so it kind of puts a stop to that
pawn takes on d4 so we do have our
exchange onboard pawn to d4 in the
Knight to e4 very interesting move in
the game decides to go and take this
pawn it looks almost weird because you
could just take the back with the night
here on e4 magnus carlsen does have this
option but very important to note if he
takes with the night then pawn to d5
this is going to take one of these
pieces on board you can see the bishop
come back here to be three let's say
pawn takes here all of a sudden the rook
could recapture and they're kind of even
in material on board magnus carlsen has
that option he decided to go a different
route and take here on f7 and now after
the rook takes and then then I can come
up here to e4 very central knight on the
board they're equal in material right
now this is how Midas Carlsen decided I
don't know which ways necessarily better
but Magnus Carlsen decided that this was
the path that he wanted to choose pawn
to d5 and the nine over here to c6 and
cardiac can kind of has a decision to
make he has a double bishop pair Magnus
Carlsen gave him that when he sacrificed
his bishop up here on f7 so he could
kind of hold on to that if he wants to
or you could just go ahead and say hey
this is a nice little outpost for this
night I don't have to worry about this
I'm gonna go ahead and take here on c5
he decides to go and hold on to it place
pawn to h6 a very critical score here on
g5 to hold on to especially since the
start square bishop has not gotten
involved into the game at all rook here
to a3 protecting this night since the
Knights come up here to c5 I just want
to make sure he has additional
protection on this knight on f3 also if
he ever wants to swing his rook over
into the King side of the board his
opponent has this F pawn gone so he
could maybe potentially think about an
attack on the King side of the board so
Bishop to f5 just getting it essentially
involved into the game and the night up
here to e5
so both of these Knights very active
ones attacking this night here on f7
cardiac context the knight on e5 we do
have a recapture on e5 and that both
sides have a
past pawn White has a passed pawn here
on e5 and then black has a passed pawn
on d5 it's actually a protected pass
pawn it has the Pawnee on c6 protecting
it so both sides are gonna be looking to
push that I do think it's gonna be tough
for either side to actually push too
much because there's just so much
material on board to block or attack
that but they have that option at least
you have to keep that in mind anytime
there is a passed pawn now the Queen
comes down here to h4 and this is I
think a pretty good move from cardiac
can put Sal OTT of pressure on his
opponent because Magnus Carlsen this
pawn is now under attack here on b4 if
this pawn were to move for any reason
the Knights would fall on c5 so that's
gonna be bad also has to keep him on if
he moves this night he doesn't have too
many great squares to move it to but
then this Bishop and this Queen are both
attacking this pawn here on f2
so that's gonna be bad something like
Knight to b3 is devastating with Bishop
down to FF 2 this is actually forced
made and not too long things get pretty
bad if we see the knight to d3 then all
of a sudden we could see bishop takes
here and then we still have that threat
of the bishop coming down here it's f2
we could also see Queen down to F 2 it
is being protected by the rook here on
f7 so all now it's pretty bad so Magnus
Carlsen decides the best way to defend
this is you actually to get a little bit
aggressive and play rook to f3 and says
you can take my pawn all you want I'm
gonna go and take your bishop so now
cardiac can decides to go ahead and
exchange material bishop takes here on
c5 pawn recaptures and then work over
here to e8 attacking this pawn right
here so Magnus Carlsen has got three
pawn chains sometimes it can be a little
more difficult to defend a multiple pawn
chain
sérgio karyakin probably has a little
better pawn structure on board he has to
it on the Queen side it's very very
strong with four altogether
rook up here to f4 attacking the Queen
Queen comes back here to e7 Queens who a
d4 since his pawn was under attack as
well as this pawn here on TV
they didn't have any protection rook to
f8 just double-barreling these rooks
here on at the F file rook down here to
f3 having a little layer of protection
with a pawn here on a g2 bit should be
for attacking the rook decides to go
ahead and exchange material here on f7
pawn to f3 forcing the bishop back here
and then a king to h2 so if we kind of
look on both sides of the board I would
say cardiac in maybe a small advance his
pieces looked a little more active I
would say he has you know the advantage
over on the Queen side I think it's
gonna be very difficult for Magnus
Carlsen do too much with this pawn here
on e5 but all in all there's not a clear
path to victory they have opposite
colored bishops that's usually gonna end
up in a more draw situation
they do have major pieces on board but
there's not really a clear advantage for
either side of the board carry that can
plays Bishop to e6 just coming back
protecting the pawn here opening up the
door for the Queen to get a little bit
more involved for Brooke to e2 Queen out
here at g6
Bishop to e3 rook here at f7 rook to f2
so both sides just consolidating
material over on the King side and then
Queen to be - so cardiac can decides to
go ahead and get material behind enemy
lines it is gonna be fairly tough to
really attack too much and do anything
this is an aggressive move so it's
always good to just put more pressure on
your opponents but unless you have more
material the Queen by itself especially
when Magnus Carlsen has so much material
to defend it's gonna be tough to really
do much with that we're cover here to be
2 attacking the Queen the Queen comes
back here to have 5 okay so that was
that was shortly lived pawn up here to
a5 just getting these pawns on opposite
colors of this LightSquared Bishop so it
kind of just negates any of the
attacking presence as this lights heard
bishop could happen that's usually what
you see with bishops on opposite colors
you have all these LightSquared pawns
over here this bishops not gonna be
doing too much especially if you kind of
lock these up then neither Bishop can
even get around that so it doesn't
negate a lot of their mobility Queen up
Queen back here to c3 keen to e8 rook to
b4
so says yeah I can start to get this
involved into the action bring it over
here to the Kings side of the board pawn
down here g5 so cardiac and decides to
go ahead and start and push a little bit
it doesn't have as many pawns as man has
crossed him but he's decides he has more
material getting ready to be involved
into the game so decides to push King
here to d8 work over here F to king c8
queen up here at d4 Queen to g6 so both
sides just slowly finding a position
that they like on board they're also
approaching the 40 minute or the 40 move
mark which they get additional time
they're in about 37 moves right now and
they don't have tons of time left on
their clock so in this particular case
you're not gonna see as many deep moves
you're gonna see more of just a
consolidation just try to slowly improve
their position but nothing too crazy
usually happening at these last moves
near move 40 punt up here to g4 pawn to
h5 so looking to kind of blow this up
Queen back here to d2 rook here to g7 a
king to g3
just adding another piece of material
involved to the action we're here to g8
came back here to g2 and Magnus Carlsen
could have tried other things beside
King here to g2 but there's not too many
things that are gonna be really great on
this board presence you know King to g2
after he was just here on h2 is not
extremely aggressive but he could decide
to take material if he wanted to
you know maybe push forward with pawn to
f4 try to blow up that side he does have
a lot of presence with the bishop the
Queen and the rook could try something
like that but all off besides to play
King hearded to g2 pawn takes on g4
recaptures would be a little trickier if
Yuri took on g4 with this pawn because
then all of a sudden Queen down here
efore check just puts too much pressure
on Magnus Carlsen doesn't want to have
to deal with that so recaptures with his
H pawn now pawn down here to d4 this is
one of those that kind of had my self
scratching my head I don't think you
have to give up this material Queen
takes here on d4 and he plays Bishop to
d5 now this is a great outpost don't get
me wrong I don't think you have to give
up your pawn in this particular case he
had
other options on board could have played
Queen 286 try to get behind enemy lines
rook over here to h8 I let me push on
the the King side I think that's way
better than just giving up upon but
decides to go ahead and give up a pawn
here on d4 Queen here to d4 Bishop to d5
I do like this outpost though and the
madness Crossland says you know what you
were you were kind enough I'm gonna go
ahead and give that pawn back to you as
well I telethia Mathis Carlson had to do
this as well I think he had other
options maybe just King to g3 it's kind
of a quiet move but he doesn't have to
give up that material right away but he
decides okay pawn to e6 my past pawn
will going to give it back
Queen takes on e6 that's fine now King
to g3 I think and move to late Queen to
e7 we're coming here to h1 trying to
control this open file on the King side
of the board Queen to f7 f4 would you
see an exchange Queen takes on f4 Queen
to e7 so cardiac ins not ready to give
up the exchange right away rook to h5
attacking the bishop but not really
doing too much does have this outpost
and there's no way to kick this off
especially since she's opponent has an
opposite colored bishop this bishops not
going anywhere on board so rook here to
f8 attacking the Queen Madison says yeah
you can go into a my queen I'll just
come up here and take years so we do see
an exchange on board and then this
particular spot they decided to draw the
game so five games five draws we come
back tomorrow
Sofia County I can has the white pieces
hopefully one of these players can break
through I don't think this was maybe as
exciting as the past two but I was happy
to see Magnus Carlsen at least tried a
new opening I wish you'd maybe try
something a little more aggressive than
the quiet two game but all in all high
level chests
always good to watch one of these
players I do think will end up winning
before we get to kind of a tiebreaker
where they play you know wrap it in
blitz chess but hopefully you guys are
enjoying the tournament even with all
the drawers thank you guys so much for
watching and I'll see y'all tomorrow